It's This American Life from WBEZ Chicago distributed by Public Radio International. A couple weeks ago, one of the producers of our show, our senior producer Julie Snyder, was out with a bunch of friends. And they ended up in a conversation where they stumbled on this thing that had happened to all of them, though they never realized how universal it was. For all of them, back they were kids, back in the '80s, their parents got divorced and then remarried. And they all agreed the re-marriage was way harder than the divorce.
这是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。几周前，我们节目的制作人之一、资深制作人朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）和一群朋友出去玩。聊天时他们无意中谈到了一件发生在每个人身上，但他们从未意识到有多普遍的事。对他们所有人来说，在80年代孩提时代，父母离婚后又再婚了。他们都一致认为，再婚带来的冲击远比离婚本身更难承受。
Divorce had come out of nothing. There had been enough literature about the whole thing and enough books about everything that was like here's how to talk to your kids about divorce. I mean, so much so that we all even had the exact-- I mean everyone had the same vocabulary about it. Number one being it's not your fault. And number two being that we love you more than anything. Mommy and daddy still love you, and you're the most important thing.
离婚来得毫无征兆。当时关于离婚的文献和书籍已经足够多了，比如“该如何跟孩子谈论离婚”。我的意思是，甚至多到我们每个人对于这事都有着相同的辞令。第一条是：这不是你的错；第二条是：我们爱你胜过一切。爸爸妈妈依然爱你，你是最重要的。
Yeah, yeah, we know you love us, yeah.
是啊，是啊，我们知道你们爱我们，行吧。
I mean, I remember even, I got told so many times that it's not your fault that it just started freaking me out after a while. I started thinking like, it never even occurred to me that this was my fault. And, after being told so much, I started thinking, like, really? Maybe this is my fault.
我的意思是，我记得我被告知“这不是你的错”太多次了，以至于过了一段时间，这反而让我感到恐慌。我开始想，我甚至从未觉得这是我的错。但被重复了太多次之后，我开始想，真的吗？难道这真的是我的错吗？
And in comparison, when the new husband, the new wife showed up, there hadn't been books about that. People didn't know what to do with that.
相比之下，当继父或继母出现时，根本没有任何相关的书。人们不知道该怎么应对这种情况。
Apparently there were not books about that, because we were all definitely the Guinea pigs for the re-marriages. And it was sort of like chaos. Everyone sort of had different stories that were just remarkable to tell. I understand that it's a really difficult thing to go through. And all of us have a lot of sympathy for our parents in this situation, and that they were trying to figure it out as they went along. But the mistakes that were made were so egregious in some situations.
显然确实没有这方面的书，因为我们所有人显然都成了再婚家庭的“小白鼠”。那简直是一片混乱。每个人都有一些令人称奇的故事。我理解这是一个非常艰难的过程。在这种情况之下，我们所有人都对父母抱有极大的同情，他们也是在摸着石头过河。但在某些情况下，他们所犯的错误实在是太离谱了。
Like for example?
比如呢？
Like one of the girls said that her dad's secretary, all of a sudden, one morning, she woke up and came into the kitchen and saw her dad's secretary standing there. And then she called her Mrs. Smith, as she always referred to her, and then the woman said to her, no, now you call me mommy. Sure, I guess so. I tend to call random women, standing at the kitchen sink in the morning, mommy. So why not?
比如其中一个女孩说，她爸爸的秘书，有一天早上她起床走进厨房，看见爸爸的秘书站在那儿。她一直称呼那位女士为“史密斯夫人”，然后那女人对她说：“不，现在你要叫我妈妈。”好吧，我想也是。我确实总是习惯在早上对着站在厨房水槽边的陌生女性叫“妈妈”。为什么不呢？
Mommy, the name that carries more meaning than anything for a child. I will grant you that name, congratulations.
“妈妈”，这个对孩子来说意义最为重大的称呼。我承认你获得了这个头衔，恭喜你。
Yeah, this is not traumatizing for me whatsoever.
是啊，这对我来说一点儿也不造成心理创伤。
How long after the parents are re-married, how long do people say that it took before the new person seemed like something other than an invading army?
在父母再婚之后，人们说要花多久，那个“新人”看起来才不再像一支入侵的军队？
I actually think that for a lot of people it took for them going away, moving out of the house.
我实际上认为，对很多人来说，直到他们离开家去住校或独立生活，才算真正跨过那道坎。
So it could be like a decade? It could be, like literally, until they were done growing up?
所以可能需要十年？真的要到他们长大成人为止？
Sure, yeah, probably until they are about 18.
没错，是的，大概要到18岁左右吧。
They never they really accepted their hearts like, this is our new family, this is the new person in our family?
他们从未真心地在内心深处接受说：“这是我们的新家庭，这是我们家的新成员”？
I don't think so. I don't think fully. There's a level of where, obviously, you accept reality. But when you're sort of being occupied, it's pretty hard to understand that they want love for you or that they feel love for you. It's a lot about just trying to get used to their relationship with your parent. It's very hard to figure out where you are in the priority list.
我觉得没有。我认为并没有完全接受。显然，在某种程度上你会接受现实。但当你感觉自己被“占领”时，很难去理解对方对你是否有爱，或者对方是否真的感受到你对他们的爱。这更多的是试图去适应他们和你父母之间的关系。你很难搞清楚自己在对方心中的优先级到底排在第几位。
Oh right, of course, because one of the things that they are, is not just your new parent, but they're basically a competitor for your other parent.
噢对了，当然，因为他们不仅是你的新家长，本质上他们还是你原先那位家长的竞争对手。
In the most literal way. For time, and affection, and energy, and for being a priority, and everything, you really are competing.
最直观地来说，为了争夺时间、关爱、精力，以及为了获得优先权，你确实是在竞争。
It's not the divorce that kills you, it's the re-marriage. Just like it's not the war that's so difficult sometimes, it's the reconstruction after-- trying to build something new, trying to put a new regime in place, even if the old regime wasn't so great. New people are jockeying for power. It's unclear who gets what, who'll get their way on a 1,000 little issues. It's hard even if everybody really wants it to go well.
真正要命的不是离婚，而是再婚。就像有时战争并不是最艰难的，最难的是战后的重建——试图建立某种新秩序，试图推行一种新政权，哪怕旧政权也没那么好。新人正在争权夺利。谁能得到什么，谁能在这一千件琐事上说了算，一切都不明确。即使每个人都真心希望事情顺利，这依然很难。
Was your step-dad the kind of person who launched like a hearts and minds campaign to win you all over and be super sweet to you, and do stuff with you and all that?
你的继父是不是那种发起“争取民心”运动，想赢得你们好感，对你们超级甜蜜，陪你们做各种事的那种人？
Yeah, he did launch a whole campaign. One of the things he did, which we all really enjoyed, was that he got us HBO. And he did away with the whole, you can't see R-movies until you're 16.
是的，他确实发起了一整套攻势。他做的一件事让我们都很喜欢，那就是他帮我们装了HBO频道。他还废除了那条“16岁之前不准看限制级电影”的规定。
Brilliant.
太棒了。
Yeah, and that I have to say, that went over big. And, oh, he cussed in front of us, which we all enjoyed. I really love my step-dad. And there were mistakes made, but they really did a lot to reassure me, and he did a lot to love me and to provide for me. I sort of feel like, maybe I even got the best you could expect. And I still would probably say, it was the most traumatizing experience of growing up.
是啊，我不得不说，这招很管用。噢，他还在我们面前说脏话，我们都很喜欢。我真的很爱我的继父。虽然他犯过错，但他确实做了很多事来安抚我，他也尽力去爱我、照顾我。我觉得我得到的可能已经是你所能期待的最好的结果了。但即使如此，我可能还是会说，这是我成长过程中最具创伤性的经历。
And you still didn't accept him until you moved out?
即便如此，你还是直到搬出去住才真正接受了他？
Not really, yeah.
确实如此。
Well today in our program, regime change. Like charity, regime change begins at home. We have three stories of the new people coming in, shaking things up, doing things their way. Forget about doing it in a foreign country with over 20 million people who don't speak your language and share your religion, even in the smallest possible setting, it's daunting.
今天我们的节目主题是“政权更迭”。就像慈善一样，政权更迭始于家庭。我们准备了三个关于新人闯入、打破旧格局、按自己方式行事的故事。别提在国外对付几千万语言不通、宗教信仰不同的人了，哪怕在最小的环境下，这也是一项艰巨的任务。
Our program today in three acts, act one, unconquerable. In that act, the story of that one store, that one place on the corner. You know what I'm talking about. Every neighborhood has one. Where the new owners come and go. New businesses come and go. And none of them can make it work, none of them can make a profit or stay very long.
我们今天的节目分为三幕。第一幕，“不可征服之地”。这一幕讲述的是街角那家店的故事。你知道我在说什么，每个街区都有这么一家店。新的经营者来来去去，新的生意此起彼伏。但没有一家能经营下去，没有一家能获利或长久生存。
Act two, or give me death. The story of a political party that wants to take over a state, impose their will on the locals, and what happens when they show up in a state that they're thinking of conquering, Vermont, and meet the natives for the very first time. Act three, the heart is a lonely junta. The story of a man reluctant to accept a very, very local regime change. Stay with us.
第二幕，“不自由毋宁死”。讲述一个政党想要接管一个州，将意志强加给当地人，而当他们出现在那个他们打算征服的州——佛蒙特州，并第一次见到当地人时，发生了什么。第三幕，“心是孤独的军政府”。讲述一个男人不情愿接受某种极其本土化的政权更迭的故事。请继续收听。
Act one-- unconquerable. There's this storefront in Washington DC, it's got location, location, and location. The neighborhood is gentrifying. Property values are high. There's lots of money everywhere. It's right by a bus stop. It's 10 minutes from the subway in the most densely populated neighborhood of the city, a place called Adams Morgan. By all rights, it should succeed. Yet every business that goes in there fails. Like some colonial country that throws off every conquering nation that tries to take it. Katie Davis has lived a block away from that storefront since she was 10 years old and decided, once and for all, she was going to look into it.
第一幕——不可征服之地。华盛顿特区有这么一个店面，地段极佳。街区正在中产阶级化，房产价值很高，到处都是钱。它就在公交站旁边，离地铁站只有10分钟路程，位于市内人口最密集的社区——亚当斯摩根区。按理说，它应该会成功。然而，进去的每家企业都失败了。就像某个殖民地，驱逐了每一个试图征服它的国家。凯蒂·戴维斯（Katie Davis）从10岁起就住在离那家店面一个街区的地方，她决定彻底查个究竟。
Everybody in the neighborhood talks about it. What's wrong with 1801 Columbia road? It's weird. The storefront straddles the biggest intersection we've got with huge wraparound windows. But they're always dark. Eight businesses have tried this space in 35 years, eight.
社区里每个人都在谈论它。哥伦比亚路1801号到底怎么了？这很怪。这个店面横跨我们这里最大的十字路口，有巨大的环绕式窗户。但它们总是黑漆漆的。35年来，有八家企业尝试过这个空间，八家。
In 1968 there was Eddie Leonard's-- incredible steak and cheese sandwiches. Then--
1968年那是埃迪·伦纳德（Eddie Leonard）的店，牛排奶酪三明治棒极了。后来——
Al bought it from Eddie. Eddie was getting old then.
艾尔（Al）从埃迪那买下了它。埃迪那时已经老了。
And it became Al's Supreme, exact same menu.
它变成了“艾尔至尊”（Al's Supreme），菜单一模一样。
Very, very greasy.
非常非常油腻。
Next, the Long John Silver's opened and never did well.
接着，“朗·约翰银子”（Long John Silver's）开了，但经营得不好。
Fish was not the appealing food at the time.
那时候鱼肉不是什么有吸引力的食物。
So for a while, it was a Latino disco with pink walls and mirrors And then a place called Cosmos.
所以有一阵子，它变成了一家带有粉红色墙壁和镜子的拉丁迪斯科舞厅。然后是一家叫“宇宙”（Cosmos）的店。
God knows what it was. It was awful.
天知道那是什么店。太烂了。
And here it gets a little fuzzy. No one can remember the name of the next place.
说到这儿，记忆有点模糊了。没人记得下一家店的名字。
OK, we had-- it's some kind of grill?
好吧，我们有过——某种烧烤店？
Then there was a Boston Market, and a kebab place that never took. And finally, a Chinese restaurant tried its luck.
后来还有一家波士顿市场（Boston Market），还有一家一直没火起来的烤肉串店。最后，一家中餐厅也试了试运气。
I don't think we could ever figure out what exactly the name was. Restaurant Number One or something like that maybe?
我想我们可能永远搞不清它的确切名字了。也许叫“一号中餐厅”之类的？
Chinese Restaurant Number One is what the sign said. But they took it down.
招牌上写的是“一号中餐厅”。但他们把招牌拆了。
And after again and again that doesn't make it, why?
一次又一次地失败，为什么？
I went to see the old-timers about the store, people who've been here forever. Mr George Dravillas holds court in the wood paneled real estate office he opened in 1953, just a half block from the storefront in question. Mr. Dravillas fingers through a withered school notebook pasted with tiny, I mean, minuscule real estate ads that go back decades. He's had his name on at least half the leases and deeds in the neighborhood, but Mr. Dravillas has never handled any transaction at 1801 Columbia Road. He has a simple explanation for why any business there is doomed.
我去找了社区里的老住户了解情况。乔治·德拉维拉斯（George Dravillas）先生在他1953年开设的木板房产办公室里接待了我，离那个店面只有半个街区。德拉维拉斯先生翻阅着一本破旧的学校笔记本，上面贴满了几十年前密密麻麻的小广告。他经手过社区里至少一半的租约和房契，但德拉维拉斯先生从未处理过哥伦比亚路1801号的任何交易。对于为什么在那里的生意注定失败，他有个简单的解释。
The corner door is the bad thing. They don't want to go through the corner door. I don't know why. I suggest that to open two stores and close the corner, then we'll have success. But they don't listen.
那个街角门是罪魁祸首。人们不想走那个街角门。我不知道为什么。我建议把两家店打通，关掉那个街角门，这样我们就会成功。但他们就是不听。
Constantine Stavropoulos has a different theory. He owns two successful restaurants in the neighborhood, and he's the head of our business association. When Constantine arrived five years ago, the neighborhood myth was that there was no daytime business. And then he opened his coffee shop, Tryst. People sat on the lumpy sofas and made it a hang-out. Pretty soon, Constantine opened a 24-hour diner just two doors down, same whomping success.
康斯坦丁·斯塔夫罗普洛斯（Constantine Stavropoulos）有不同的理论。他在社区里拥有两家成功的餐厅，还是商会的负责人。康斯坦丁五年前刚来时，社区的传说是这里没有白天生意。然后他开了咖啡馆“Tryst”。人们坐在凹凸不平的沙发上，把它变成了聚会场所。很快，康斯坦丁在两扇门外开了家24小时餐厅，同样大获成功。
So the guy has instincts along with his MBA. And when Constantine had a chance to open his diner at 1801 Columbia Road, those instincts told him, stay away. 1801 only looks like a good location, he says. Really, it's a mirage. People are at that intersection but never on that corner.
所以这位仁兄不仅有工商管理硕士（MBA）学位，还有敏锐的直觉。当康斯坦丁有机会在哥伦比亚路1801号开餐厅时，直觉告诉他：离远点。他说，1801号看起来位置很好，实际上是个海市蜃楼。人们会经过那个路口，但从不在那个角落停留。
It might be, I don't know, crowd dynamics or something that sort of get people into this thinking that they don't want to hike across the street and go over there. So in a way, it's like this little island. You can see it, but it's a question of just getting to it.
这可能是，我不知道，人群动力学之类的东西，让人们产生了一种不想穿过马路去那边的心理。所以在某种程度上，它就像是一座孤岛。你能看见它，但问题是怎么去到那里。
At this point, it might help if you picture the corner. 18th and Columbia Road has wide roomy streets and bus stops on three sides. There's a bank and a McDonald's that's always busy. To the south, there are 60 businesses crammed into the first and second floors. All of this feeds into the intersection. Just a few steps to the north, though, all retail stops, taken over by somber row-homes, a dead zone merging into dead space. Which brings us to the whole chicken and egg problem of how to explain this corner. Do businesses fail because there's no foot traffic? Or is there no foot traffic because the businesses are crummy?
此时，如果能想象一下那个角落会有帮助。18街和哥伦比亚路有宽阔的街道，三面都有公交站。那里有一家银行和一家永远生意兴隆的麦当劳。向南，有60家企业挤在一楼和二楼。所有这些都汇入了路口。然而，向北走几步，零售商店就消失了，取而代之的是阴沉的连排住宅，是一个融入死空间的死亡地带。这把我们带回了鸡生蛋还是蛋生鸡的问题：为什么会这样？是因为没有行人流量导致生意失败？还是因为生意太差导致没有行人流量？
Gee, is it warm enough for you out there?
嘿，外面够暖和吗？
Mention the failed storefront to Sid Drazin at Comet Liquor and Deli and be prepared to stick around for a while as he launches into his business-according-to-Sid talk. He paces behind the register, lecturing, ringing up a turkey on rye. He says, remember the guys who leased the storefront back in 1995 and opened a Boston Market franchise? They were sure roasted chicken would draw a crowd.
在“彗星酒水熟食店”（Comet Liquor and Deli）向西德·德拉津（Sid Drazin）提起那家失败的店面，准备好听他开始一场“西德生意经”。他在收银台后徘徊，一边演讲，一边给一份黑麦火鸡三明治结账。他说，记得1995年租下那个店面开波士顿市场特许经营店的那帮人吗？他们确信烤鸡能吸引人群。
They sat in my place six months before they did it and asked me my opinion. I told him they were crazy if they opened it up. And they continued to tell me there's 15,000 cars go by there every day. There's close to 4,000 or 5,000 people walking around in the neighborhood. They'd have to get 5%, maybe 1%, but they'd do enough. And I looked at them, and I said, have you ever been in business, gentlemen? And they said, no, we're MBA's. And when we have that much traffic going by and so forth, we have to calculate that's enough to make our payroll and everything else. I said, OK, you want to throw your money away, be my guest.
他们开业前六个月就坐在我的店里问我的意见。我告诉他们，如果在那开店他们就是疯了。他们一直跟我说每天有1.5万辆车经过那里，附近有四五千人走动，只要争取到5%，甚至1%的客源就够了。我看着他们说：“各位，你们做过生意吗？”他们说：“没有，我们是MBA。”当有那么大流量时，我们必须计算出这足够支付薪水和一切开销。我说：“好吧，你们想把钱扔掉，请便。”
The Boston Market guys didn't listen to him. Sid's been four doors down from the corner for 22 years, and they didn't listen. They opened and folded after two years and two months. As we talk about this, Sid sighs, over and over. Look, he says, the only way you'll draw people to that store is if you make it a designated corner.
波士顿市场那帮人没听他的。西德在那个角落四个门面之外开了22年店了，他们没听他的。他们开了两年零两个月就关门了。谈到这里，西德不停地叹气。看，他说，让人们去那家店的唯一方法就是把它变成一个“指定目的点”。
Designated means that it's a item that people need and will go to regardless of where it's at. If it's a good cleaner, I don't care where it is. They'll stop go in and get out. If it's a drug store, has good prices, service, and what they need, they'll go to it. If it's a shoe store, a shoe repair, which is none in the area, everybody needs it.
指定目的点是指人们需要的东西，不管它在哪儿都会特意跑去买。如果是一家好的干洗店，我不在乎它在哪，人们会停下来去取衣服。如果是一家药店，价格公道、服务好且货品齐全，人们就会去。如果是一家鞋店或修鞋店，该地区目前没有，每个人都需要修鞋。
Let me take one of those. Here's the problem with shoe repair. The rent at 1801 is about $10,000 a month. High for the neighborhood, but not unheard of. Shoe makers charge $25 for a new leather sole. You'd have to have 400 come in every month with an old shoe just to make the rent, not to mention taxes, insurance, and a couple of employees.
让我拿一份那个。修鞋的问题是这样的，1801号的租金大约每月1万美元。在这个街区算高，但也并非闻所未闻。修鞋匠换个皮底收费25美元。你每个月得有400人带着旧鞋来，才能付得起房租，更别提税收、保险和雇员了。
Or you'd have to do what Sid does at Comet Liquor and Deli. There's nothing in the store you can't get at other places in the neighborhood. He sells bagels to the yuppies, truffles to old ladies, and pint-sized bottles of vodka to the guys who drink on the corner. And there's a copy machine that's broken most of the time. It's a store held together by sheer force of personality. People come for Sid.
或者你得像西德在酒水熟食店那样做。店里没什么东西是你在社区别处买不到的。他卖贝果给雅皮士，松露给老太太，小瓶伏特加给在角落喝酒的家伙。还有一台大部分时间都在坏的复印机。这家店是靠纯粹的个人魅力维系的。人们是为了西德才来的。
The thing of it is, it is a designated spot in the community. I made it such. In other words, if you're there as a person, and you take the community into your bosom or so-called hands, or you are willing to join the community and be part of it? Then it becomes a designated thing.
问题的关键是，它确实是社区里的一个指定点。我把它变成了这样。换句话说，如果你作为一个人，把社区拥入怀中，或者愿意加入社区并成为其中一部分，那么它就成了一个指定的事物。
The bosom theory makes sense to Mary Godwin, although she differs on what it takes to hold the community close. She says, she used to march into 1801 Columbia Road and tell the owner.
这种“怀抱理论”对玛丽·戈德温（Mary Godwin）来说很有道理，尽管她对如何留住社区有不同看法。她说，她以前常冲进哥伦比亚路1801号告诉店主。
Get a bar in here. You don't remember. He didn't even have a bar in there. You can't make it around here without a bar. I really think so. I say, yeah, you got to have a bar around this neighborhood.
“在这儿开个酒吧吧。”你不记得了。他甚至连个酒吧都没有。在这儿没个酒吧你根本开不下去。我真的这么认为。我说，在这片儿你非得有个酒吧不可。
Mary was a neighborhood star back in the 1950's when she was a champion roller skater, and then tended bar down at Millie & Al's. Mary always wanted to own a pub with regulars. She always wanted to put it at 1801, but whenever it came up for lease, she never had the cash. If only though, if only Mary had gotten that lease, her husband Tony would have worked the door. They would have called it Bailey's.
玛丽在1950年代是社区明星，她是轮滑冠军，后来在“米莉与艾尔”（Millie & Al's）酒吧当过酒保。玛丽一直想拥有一家有常客的酒吧。她一直想把店开在1801号，但每次店面招租时，她都没有现金。如果，哪怕只是如果玛丽拿到了那个租约，她的丈夫托尼（Tony）就会在门口看店。他们会把它叫作“贝利酒吧”（Bailey's）。
I told Tony, I guarantee you, if you and I had go that place some time ago, it would've been the neighborhood bar.
我告诉托尼，我敢保证，如果我们早些时候拿下了那个地方，它绝对会成为社区酒吧。
At that time, the people we knew, and the people that would follow Mary and come and listen to me with my stories, we would have been successful. But them people are dead or have moved on. It's a different generation. I'm not into the college set. I'm from the coal mines, and Mary's a skater and a waitress.
那时候，我们认识的人，那些愿意追随玛丽并听我讲故事的人，我们肯定会成功。但那些人要么去世了，要么搬走了。这是不同的一代人。我对大学那一套不感兴趣。我是从煤矿出来的，玛丽是滑冰手兼服务员。
There was a time that storefront flourished. It was in the early 1970's when it was Eddie Leonard's, a sandwich shop owned by an ex-boxer.
曾经有一段时间那个店面很繁荣。那是在70年代初，当时它是埃迪·伦纳德（Eddie Leonard）的店，一家由前拳击手经营的三明治店。
Guys, you had lines out the door, sometimes, at 3:00 in the morning.
伙计，有时候凌晨3点门外都排着长队。
I never saw lines out the door, but I was at home being 12. I know my mom went there after bar-hopping. My friend, Reggie, had a few years on me, and he made 1801 Columbia Road home base, ordering a $0.10 Coke and hanging out for hours on the orange plastic chairs. He says, by 3:00 in the morning, everyone in the place was drunk, high, or trying to get high.
我从未见过排长队，但我那时才12岁，都在家里。我知道我妈在泡完吧后去过那里。我的朋友雷吉（Reggie）比我大几岁，他把哥伦比亚路1801号当成了大本营，点一杯10美分的可乐，在橙色塑料椅上坐几个小时。他说，到凌晨3点，店里每个人要么喝醉了，要么磕了药，要么正准备磕。
Because on 18th Street, you had the Showboat Lounge, and you had Manuel's nightclub. You're always going to get a good show around closing time, because whenever the bars close, people get hungry.
因为在18街，你有“秀船酒廊”（Showboat Lounge）和曼努埃尔夜总会。关门时间前后你总能看到好戏，因为酒吧一关门，人们就饿了。
Back then 1801 was a destination, an open house for the neighborhood. Women clicked through the door in their heels, Afros and beehives jutting up. Men in popcorn shirts and platform shoes, gamblers, bouncers, dancers, they all came in. Reggie says that the night pizza-man at 1801 was a 17 year old everyone called by his childhood nickname, Stinky.
那时1801号是个目的地，是社区的公共休息室。女士们踩着高跟鞋进来，顶着爆炸头和蜂窝头。男士们穿着波普衫和松糕鞋，赌徒、保镖、舞者，他们都来了。雷吉说，1801号的夜班披萨师傅是个17岁的孩子，大家都叫他小时候的绰号——“臭臭”（Stinky）。
Stinky was weird. Stinky was, I guess, what you would call a nerd now-a-days, when we were kids. He was one of those people who wanted to be a gangster but always got caught.
“臭臭”很古怪。我想，如果是现在的话，你会称他为“书呆子”。小时候，他就是那种想当黑帮却总是被抓的人。
No one said this to Stinky's face though. He was six foot five, 230 pounds and already hard from 22 juvenile arrests and reform school. People steered clear of Stinky. He carried a gun, and he robbed people, sometimes a half block from that corner where he worked.
不过没人敢当面这么说。他身高6英尺5英寸（约1.96米），体重230磅（约104公斤），因为22次未成年人逮捕记录和教养所经历，他已经变得很强硬。人们对“臭臭”敬而远之。他随身带枪，抢劫路人，有时就在他工作的那个路口半个街区外。
When they finally caught him, they charged him with 69 crimes. So he was busy in this neighborhood, in this neighborhood alone. And what happened was, apparently he robbed this woman in the Mews, Kalorama Mews, those townhomes. And she wasn't that old, and she knew karate, and she tried to use it on him. And he shot her a couple times in the face, and, I believe, he stabbed her, but she didn't die. Matter of fact, she drew-- she must have been an artist-- she drew the wanted poster.
他们最终抓住他时，指控了他69项罪名。所以他单在这个社区就非常“忙碌”。事情是这样的，显然他在“缪斯”（Mews，指卡洛拉玛缪斯连排住宅）抢劫了一位女士，她年纪不大，而且会空手道，她试着对他反击。他朝她脸上开了几枪，我记得他还刺伤了她，但她没死。事实上，她画了一幅——她肯定是个艺术家——她画出了嫌犯肖像。
And they posted them all around the neighborhood. And he wasn't the brightest guy in the world. He had this one particular outfit, a green leather jacket, I think, a brown leather baseball cap that he would wear whenever he'd commit crimes. And everybody in the neighborhood knew it, because they posted what he'd had on. And everybody knew it was him.
他们把肖像贴满了社区。但他并不是世界上最聪明的人。他有一件特定的行头：一件绿色皮夹克，我想还有一顶棕色皮棒球帽，每次犯罪他都会穿戴。社区里的每个人都知道，因为他们贴出了他的装束。大家都知道那就是他。
In the end, the building gave Stinky up. He stood right in the windows of 1801 twirling pizzas wearing that baseball cap. Police made the connection, and stinky got 37 years to life. Just a couple years later when the sandwich shop closed, the string of failures started.
最后，那栋建筑出卖了“臭臭”。他就站在1801号的窗户里，戴着那顶棒球帽转着披萨饼。警察建立了联系，“臭臭”被判了37年到终身监禁。仅仅几年后，那家三明治店关门了，一连串的失败开始了。
Even people who don't know the real story will tell you, a murderer worked there, and that's what went wrong. The local weekly once wrote a story about the corner and headlined it, "The Curse of Stinky." Nearly everyone I spoke with eventually got around to the idea of a curse. Here's Mr. Dravillas when he was trying to explain the problem with the door at 1801 Columbia Road.
即使是不知道内幕的人也会告诉你，一个杀人犯曾在那里工作，这就是出问题的原因。当地周刊曾写过关于那个角落的故事，标题是“臭臭的诅咒”。我采访的几乎每个人最终都提到了诅咒的想法。这是德拉维拉斯先生试图解释1801号哥伦比亚路的问题时说的话。
Explain to me, what's the problem with the corner?
跟我解释一下，那个角落到底有什么问题？
Curse-- the door.
诅咒——门。
Or here's Mark Winstead checking a rim up the block at City Bikes.
或者是马克·温斯特德（Mark Winstead）在街区的“城市自行车”（City Bikes）修车时的说法。
There's some voodoo going on. It's like the Bermuda Triangle of small business.
这儿有伏都教作祟。这就像小企业的百慕大三角。
And this is Pat Patrick, another big real estate broker.
这是帕特·帕特里克（Pat Patrick），另一位大型房地产经纪人。
That is just a damning site. It's all there is to it.
那简直是个该死的地方。这就是全部原因。
A damning site?
一个该死的地方？
Well, yeah, it's jinxed.
嗯，是的，它被诅咒了。
On the other hand, maybe for a neighborhood to be in balance there has to be an accursed storefront, the one corner that everyone rolls their eyes at, the problem child. It brings people together, and it gives us something we can all agree on.
另一方面，也许为了让社区保持平衡，必须有一个被诅咒的店面，一个每个人都嗤之以鼻的“问题儿童”。它能把人们聚在一起，让我们都有一个共同的话题。
So Starbucks, that's the latest. Starbucks signed a lease at 1801. They're going to load in a bunch of Sumatra beans and Kenyan blend, put cushy chairs in the windows and offer wireless access. How, you might wonder, how can 1801 Columbia Road trip up Starbucks? They've got 4,000 stores. They've got to have the formula down pat, know exactly what makes people walk in and order a Frappuccino.
所以星巴克，这是最新的入驻者。星巴克签下了1801号的租约。他们要运来一堆苏门答腊咖啡豆和肯尼亚拼配豆，在窗边放上舒适的椅子，并提供无线上网。你可能在想，星巴克怎么可能被哥伦比亚路1801号绊倒？他们有4000家店。他们一定摸透了门道，精准地知道什么能让人走进店里点一杯星冰乐。
All you can have to do is stand here and know. It's 11:30 and it's packed.
你只需站在这儿就知道了。现在是11点半，店里挤满了人。
Starbucks regional marketing director, Shannon Jones, stands in the doorway of 1801. She offers the track record. Starbucks has 35 stores in Washington DC and has never closed one.
星巴克区域营销总监香农·琼斯（Shannon Jones）站在1801号的门口。她列出了辉煌战绩：星巴克在华盛顿特区有35家店，从未关过一家。
We've been looking at Adams Morgan for two and a half plus years, trying to get the right space here for the neighborhood. And finally, the stars aligned, and we were able to get the this great space on the corner.
我们关注亚当斯摩根区两年半多了，一直在为社区寻找合适的空间。终于，时机成熟，我们拿下了街角这个绝佳的店面。
She says this, and I want to say, which stars are you talking about? Think about it though. Starbucks has a product that's physically addictive, and enough money to wait forever for the store to turn a profit. The neighborhood's full of office workers, freelancers, dot-commers, and consultants. Shannon Jones says, what ruins other businesses is often what works for Starbucks. Take the lack of parking, not a problem.
她说这话时，我真想问：你说的时机成熟是指什么？不过想想看，星巴克有一种让人生理上瘾的产品，而且有足够的钱可以等上很久直到店铺盈利。社区里住满了上班族、自由职业者、互联网从业者和顾问。香农·琼斯说，毁掉其他生意的因素往往是星巴克成功的关键。比如停车位不足，这不是问题。
It's amazing, the way that people, even when they're in their car, will find a way to get in to Starbucks and get their drinks. So what we really look for is also a great storefront.
很神奇，人们即使在开车时，也会想方设法进星巴克买杯咖啡。所以我们真正看重的是一个绝佳的店面。
I want to run a couple of theories by you for why previous tenants haven't worked. And one is, we're standing right under it. There is one realtor in the neighborhood who thinks that the door should be moved.
我想和你探讨一下为什么之前的租户都失败的几种理论。其中之一就在我们头顶。社区里有一位房产经纪人认为门应该换个位置。
Absolutely not. One of our busiest stores in Washington is Liberty Place, and it has, literally, the same kind of entrance. It's kind of on a corner, kind of tucked in, and, literally, that store is probably no more than a 1,000 square feet, and the volume that it does. In terms of the entrance, definitely, we're excited about where this entrance is, and where it sits, because, I mean, it looks out on the entire neighborhood. So this was one thing we knew we didn't want to change.
绝对不行。我们在华盛顿最忙的店之一是自由广场店，它入口的设计几乎和这里一样。它也就在街角，有点隐蔽，但那家店只有不到1000平方英尺，客流量却惊人。关于入口，我们对它目前的位置和坐向感到非常兴奋，因为它能俯瞰整个社区。所以这是我们知道绝对不想改变的一点。
Another theory is that this is sort of an island, and you can't get people to cross over for some reason. No one can really explain why it's an island, but I wonder what you think about that?
另一个理论是这里是一座孤岛，出于某种原因人们不愿走过来。没人能解释为什么它是座孤岛，但你觉得呢？
I think again that people want to come into Starbucks, which is great. People need their coffee, and they'll cross streets for it.
我认为人们还是想进星巴克，这很好。人们需要咖啡，为了咖啡他们会过马路的。
And then the last one is this. When some people have tried to explain to me why other people haven't made it, they just flat out say, well, I think the place is jinxed. I think there's a curse. So what do you say to them?
最后一个是这样。当有人试着解释为什么别人都没能撑下去时，他们直接说：“噢，我觉得这地方邪门。我觉得有个诅咒。”你怎么回应他们？
I actually say-- and it's funny, because we've heard all of these things too-- and we're here to stay. And I think everybody will be happy to see us here when we're celebrating our 20th anniversary in Washington.
我实际上会说——这很有趣，因为我们也听过所有这些说法——我们是来扎根的。我相信当我们庆祝在华盛顿开店20周年时，每个人都会很高兴看到我们在这里。
At the end of the interview, I have to say I'm sold. Starbucks will be the one that makes it. When I float this, Pat the realtor predicts Starbucks will last 13 months, no longer. And Sid, well, Sid can't help himself. He just double, double dares them to try.
采访结束时，我不得不说我被说服了。星巴克会是那个成功的案例。当我提到这点时，房地产经纪人帕特预测星巴克最多只能撑13个月。而西德嘛，他忍不住了。他简直在用“双倍赌注”挑战他们。
Nobody's been in there for a long period of time. Boston Market went running real quick. Long John Silver's disappeared. What do you think, those people don't know what business is, that Starbucks knows everything? OK, we'll find out. Let them have it, and we'll watch them go into the ground.
没人能在那里长久待下去。波士顿市场跑得飞快，“朗·约翰银子”消失了。你认为那些人不懂生意，难道星巴克就全懂？好吧，我们走着瞧。让他们试吧，我们等着看他们破产。
The truth is though, many people will cross their fingers for the new Starbucks. They've been waiting for someone to light up those windows. Because as entertaining as it is to project all this drama onto that corner, it would be a relief to see someone figure out what works there. Every time it goes dark, you get this feeling that the dead space is gaining power. That it's swallowing up projects, life savings, and dreams. You start to use the other side of the street.
但事实是，许多人会为这家新星巴克祈祷。他们一直在等有人能点亮那些窗户。因为尽管把所有这些戏剧性因素投射到那个角落很有趣，但看到有人解决了那个难题确实会让人如释重负。每次它熄灯，你就会觉得那个“死亡空间”正在增强力量。它在吞噬创业项目、毕生积蓄和梦想。你开始绕道走街的另一边。
Katie Davis in Washington DC. Coming up, casing the state of Vermont before you try to take it all. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
凯蒂·戴维斯在华盛顿特区报道。接下来，在试图征服整个州之前先侦察一下佛蒙特州。节目稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, regime change in everyday life. Stories of the new people coming in, taking over, full of hubris. And how hard it is to win over the locals even in the most mundane of settings.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来一系列不同类型的故事。今天的节目主题是：日常生活中的政权更迭。讲述新人闯入、接管一切，充满傲慢的故事。以及即便在最平凡的环境下，要赢得当地人的认可有多难。
We've arrived at act two of our program, act two, or give me death. Libertarians, you've probably heard of them, right? Maybe you aren't exactly sure what they stand for. All right, here is a short list: no gun laws, no restrictions on drug use, no income tax. And I'll say that one again, no taxes. They'd like to make government as small as humanly possible. Maybe you also know, they almost never get elected to office, any office. Last year a guy named Jason Sorens came up with a plan to remedy that. His plan, gather up some 20,000 libertarians, move to a state, a small state, vote the friends into office, and then slowly take over. Sarah Koenig got herself invited to a recruiting meeting of The Free State Project.
我们进入节目的第二幕，“不自由毋宁死”。自由意志主义者，你大概听说过吧？可能你不确定他们主张什么。好吧，这里有个简短列表：没有枪支法，没有药物管制，没有所得税。我再重复一遍，没有税收。他们想把政府规模缩小到人类所能承受的极限。也许你还知道，他们几乎从不赢得选举，任何公职都选不上。去年，一个叫杰森·索伦斯（Jason Sorens）的家伙想出了一个办法。他的计划是：召集约2万名自由意志主义者，搬到一个州，一个小州，把朋友投进公职，然后慢慢接管。萨拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）受邀参加了“自由州计划”的招募会议。
The meeting was in College Park, Maryland at a restaurant designed to look like a French farmhouse. About 35 people were waiting for Jason to arrive. I thought they were going to be sort of like republicans, only more so but that wasn't quite it. There was something at once bookish and eager about them, like people in love with an idea and happy to chat about it if you show the least amount of interest. This is Nixie Chesnovitch. She looks nothing like my libertarian stereotype. She's young and hip and has cropped purple hair.
会议在马里兰州的大学公园市一家装修成法国农舍风格的餐厅举行。大约35人在等待杰森的到来。我原以为他们会像共和党人，只是程度更深一点，但事实并非如此。他们身上有一种既书卷气又热切的气质，就像那些爱上某种理念，如果你表现出哪怕一点兴趣，他们就乐于畅谈的人。这位是尼克西·切斯诺维奇（Nixie Chesnovitch）。她看起来一点也不像我心目中的自由意志主义者刻板印象。她年轻时髦，留着短碎紫发。
I often think about what it must have been like for the founders of this nation. They were trying a very radical sort of idea. When they signed the Declaration of Independence they thought they were signing away their lives, and yet they did it.
我经常想，这个国家的缔造者们当时是什么心情。他们在尝试一种非常激进的理念。当他们签署《独立宣言》时，他们以为自己在拿生命冒险，但他们还是签了。
You got tears in your eyes when you were talking about the founding fathers.
你谈到国父们的时候眼里有泪花。
I guess-- I think it's kind of egotistical to say that I think about The Free State Project that way, that I am founding a whole new nation. But I do think that we are carrying on the founder's dreams. They said that if you see tyranny, you have to do something about that. Here's a Republic if you can keep it.
我想……如果我说我在考虑“自由州计划”时有这种感觉，认为自己在建立一个全新的国家，这可能有点自负。但我确实认为我们在继承缔造者的梦想。他们说，如果你看到暴政，你就必须采取行动。这就是“一个共和国，如果你能守护住它的话”。
Tyranny might sound a bit extreme coming from these people; they hardly seem oppressed. They have multiple degrees, good jobs, some with the government, families, and they like where they live. So what's their big complaint? It's not only that there are too many tax laws and too many gun laws. There are too many laws period. They all have this injured feeling that it wasn't supposed to be this way. As if the promise of American freedom born in 1776 was made to them personally, and 227 years later everyone but them has forgotten.
从这群人嘴里说出“暴政”可能听起来有点极端；他们看起来一点也不受压迫。他们有多个学位，有好工作，有的还在政府工作，有家庭，而且他们喜欢自己住的地方。那么他们最大的抱怨是什么？不仅仅是税法太多，枪支法太多。是法律太多了，期间。他们都有种受伤害的感觉，好像事情本不该是这样。仿佛1776年诞生的美国自由承诺是专门给他们的，而227年过去了，除了他们，所有人都忘了。
I can't tell if I'm breaking a law. It has gotten to the point where there's so many laws on the books that by carrying a simple lock-blade knife in some states, which is a common accouterment where I'm from, it's something you just have.
我甚至分不清我是否在违法。现在的法律多到这种程度，在某些州携带一把简单的折叠锁扣刀——这在我家乡是一种常见的配件，你随身带着——竟然是违法的。
She's from rural Tennessee.
她来自田纳西州的乡村。
That is illegal in some states. I mean, it's illegal to carry pliers in your pocket in Texas, I learned last night. It's just ridiculous.
在某些州那是违法的。我的意思是，我昨晚才知道，在德克萨斯州口袋里装把钳子都是违法的。这太荒谬了。
Jason Sorens arrives. It turns out the leader of this revolution is 26 years old and looks about 19. He's wearing a white turtleneck, pale-blue jeans, and resembles a dark-haired Macaulay Culkin. I wonder if maybe this is all part of some experiment for his doctorate, which he is getting in political science at Yale. It isn't. He stands in front of the gathering while they order food-- mostly burgers and curly fries-- and lays out the plan.
杰森·索伦斯到了。这位革命领袖年仅26岁，看起来像19岁。他穿着高领白毛衣，浅蓝色牛仔裤，长得像深色头发的麦考利·卡尔金（Macaulay Culkin）。我怀疑这是否是他政治学博士研究实验的一部分。其实不是。他在大家点餐——主要是汉堡和卷曲薯条——的时候站在人群前，阐述了他的计划。
Thanks Steve, and it's good to see you all here. For those of you not completely familiar with the Free State Project, we're circulating a statement of intent, basically saying that you agree to move to a single state of the US. Once 20,000 people sign up, the move begins. And there is a five year period in which to move.
谢谢史蒂夫，很高兴见到大家。对于那些不完全了解“自由州计划”的人，我们正在分发一份意向书，基本上说的是你同意搬到美国的一个特定州。一旦有2万人报名，迁移就开始。这期间有五年的迁移期。
Hearing him talk, you feel not so much as if you're in the presence of a political rabble browser, but a supremely intelligent and gentle rabbit. The initial goals of the Free State Project, he tells them, would be to get rid of taxes, privatize all public schools, and abolish eminent domain and zoning laws.
听他讲话，你感觉到的不是站在暴民煽动者面前，而是一只极其聪明且温顺的兔子。他告诉大家，“自由州计划”的初步目标是取消税收，私有化所有公立学校，废除征用权和分区法。
He thinks the 20,000 and their allies could start to win local elections by the year 2010. By 2020 they'd have state offices. A governor and a sympathetic state supreme court by about 2025. The project is about freedom, so bigots and homophobes need not sign up. And yes, they have a mascot. A cartoon porcupine because Jason says, it's cute and not aggressive, but you wouldn't want to mess with it.
他认为这2万人及其盟友可以在2010年开始赢得地方选举。到2020年，他们将拥有州公职。大约到2025年，能拥有一位州长和一个持同情态度的州最高法院。这个项目是为了自由，所以偏执狂和恐同者不必报名。是的，他们有吉祥物：一只卡通豪猪，因为杰森说它很可爱，不具攻击性，但你不会想去招惹它。
Later Jason tells me how it all started. Libertarians have been derisively called the party of 2%, because there's so few of them. Jason thought, well there are fifty states, each is 2% of the Union, why not all move to one?
后来杰森告诉我一切是怎么开始的。自由意志主义者一直被嘲笑为“2%党”，因为他们人数太少。杰森想，美国有50个州，每个州占联邦的2%，为什么不全都搬到一个州呢？
Well, I wrote this essay for The Libertarian Enterprise , which is an online journal, and I submitted it to the editor, and he was really excited about it and thought it was really good. I said, oh, maybe this idea isn't so bad after all her. And he decided to publish it. The next day I had gotten probably 60 or 70 email messages. And they kept coming in the days after that. About 200 total saying, let's do this. Let's do this project.
我在一个在线期刊《自由企业》（The Libertarian Enterprise）上写了这篇文章，提交给编辑，他非常兴奋，认为这真的很棒。我说：“噢，也许这个想法还不错。”他决定发表。第二天我大概收到了60到70封电子邮件。之后的几天里它们源源不断。总共约有200封说：“做吧，让我们执行这个项目。”
Libertarians have tried other projects, some have sounded like sci-fi: a long term rental of a valley in Somalia, or building a city on pylons somewhere off the coast of Honduras. By comparison Jason's plan seems eminently sensible. Before he knew it , he was in charge of a somewhat ragtag internet movement, one he now works on practically full-time. The website, which Jason created, includes statistical analyses of each state under consideration. Prospective members learn encouraging facts like that the cheapest place to mount a political campaign is North Dakota, and that Alaska has the lowest state and local taxes.
自由意志主义者尝试过其他项目，有些听起来像科幻小说：长期租赁索马里的一片山谷，或者在洪都拉斯海岸外的桩基上建一座城市。相比之下，杰森的计划看起来极其理性。在他还没反应过来时，他就负责了一个稍微有点乱七八糟的互联网运动，他现在几乎全职投入其中。杰森创建的网站包括对每个候选州的统计分析。潜在成员会学到一些令人振奋的事实，比如在北达科他州发起政治运动最便宜，阿拉斯加的州和地方税收最低。
The government has treated the Constitution like a dirty rag, basically. There was a time when it was clear that the government didn't have any role in education, social security, or crime control. That's a state matter, not for the federal government. And now the federal government does all those things. I've never had anyone adequately explain to me why we needed an amendment for alcohol prohibition, yet drug prohibition requires no such amendment. The government simply does it, and there is no constitutional grounds for opposing it, apparently.
政府基本上把宪法当成了脏抹布。曾经有一段时间，很明确政府在教育、社会保障或犯罪控制方面没有任何作用。那是州内事务，不是联邦政府的事。现在联邦政府做了所有这些事。从没人能充分向我解释为什么酒精禁令需要宪法修正案，而药物禁令却不需要。政府就直接做了，显然没有任何宪法依据来反对它。
Jason's not like anybody I've ever met. He's so steeped in theory that even when the tape recorder isn't rolling it's hard to get him to talk like an ordinary person, like someone who isn't say, actually participating in the Constitutional Convention.
杰森不像我见过的任何人。他沉浸在理论中，以至于即便在录音机关掉时，也很难让他像普通人那样说话，就像一个不是正在参与制宪会议的人。
But no one at the meeting seems fazed by this. Maybe it's just his elegant posture and impossibly clear skin, but Jason has this quiet charisma. He seems selfless, and so completely motivated by his idea that when you're around him, you wonder if this is someone you'll talk about some day and say, I met him when he was 26, before anyone had heard of him. People ask him questions about his favorite state on the list, but as the leader, he demurs.
但会议上没人觉得不对劲。也许只是他优雅的姿态和无可挑剔的皮肤，杰森有一种安静的魅力。他看起来无私，而且完全被他的理念所驱动，以至于当你在他身边时，你会想：这会不会是未来某天我跟人聊起时会说“我在他26岁、还没人听过他名字的时候就见过他”的那个人？人们问他关于候选州里最喜欢哪一个，但他作为领导者总是推辞。
One guy asks about states with long coastlines and the s-word. And for a minute I have no idea what he's talking about.
有个家伙问起拥有漫长海岸线的州和那个“S开头”的词。我有一分钟完全不知道他在说什么。
Wouldn't it be kind of easier to do the s-word with a state like Delaware or somebody like that or even Alaska, rather than something like Wyoming, because it's kind of hardest if they decided to close airspace. You're not going to get anybody in or out, that kind of thing.
如果选择像特拉华州或阿拉斯加那样的州，而不是像怀俄明州，会不会更容易执行那个“S”计划？因为如果他们决定关闭领空，你就没法进出了。
Then I realize he's talking about secession. Consider this, more than 3,000 people have already pledged to move. When the list reaches 5,000, they'll choose a destination from the 10 states. Jason expects that to happen this year. One of the candidate states is Vermont. Yes, Vermont, the only state that elected a socialist to Congress. Jason gets invited to Vermont to talk to a property-rights group about his project, and I go along.
然后我意识到他在说“分裂”（Secession）。考虑一下，已经有超过3000人承诺搬迁。当名单达到5000人时，他们将从10个候选州中选出一个目的地。杰森预计今年就会发生。候选州之一是佛蒙特州。是的，佛蒙特，唯一一个选出社会主义者进入国会的州。杰森受邀去佛蒙特州向一个财产权组织谈论他的项目，我也随行。
We pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America--
我们宣誓效忠美利坚合众国国旗——
It's in a Best Western conference room in the town of Waterbury. About 40 people show up, mostly conservative Republicans wearing sensible winter boots and carrying mugs of coffee from home. This is a good crowd for him. What he calls, liberty friendly. We learned that adding 20,000 people to the state could actually swing some local races. The only libertarian in the state legislature just lost reelection by 127 votes. David McCullough is an eighth generation Vermonter, and a former state rep.
会议是在沃特伯里镇的一家贝斯特韦斯特酒店会议室举行的。大约40人到场，主要是穿着舒适冬靴、带着自家咖啡杯的保守派共和党人。这是他的好听众。他称他们为“自由友好型”。我们得知，向该州增加2万人实际上可以撼动一些地方选举。州议会中唯一的自由意志主义者刚以127票之差输掉连任。大卫·麦卡洛（David McCullough）是佛蒙特州的第八代居民，也是前州众议员。
Vermont is still small. 600,000 people and like 220,000 don't vote. And when they don't vote, they're yours baby in politics. People are sheep, that's my opinion. They're interested in the football game. In Rome, they had the gladiators. It's the same, exact thing. You talk, I don't do politics, I just do football. I don't do politics, I just do snow-machining. I don't do politics, I'm just into arm-wrestling or whatever.
佛蒙特州仍然很小。60万人，大概22万人不去投票。当他们不投票时，在政治上他们就是你的囊中之物。人们是绵羊，这是我的观点。他们只对足球赛感兴趣。在罗马，他们有角斗士。完全一样。你谈话时，他们说“我不搞政治，我只看足球”。我不搞政治，我只搞雪地摩托。我不搞政治，我只喜欢掰手腕，之类的。
We took a quick poll of the room. About five people said they'd be interested in signing up for the project. One of them is Bill Sayre, a lobbyist for the forestry industry and a dead ringer for Ted Koppel. He tells Jason how encouraging it is to see someone so young with such promising new ideas about liberty. And then he signs the pledge.
我们对房间里的人做了一个快速民意调查。大约五个人表示有兴趣报名参加项目。其中一位是比尔·塞尔（Bill Sayre），林业游说者，长得极像泰德·科佩尔（Ted Koppel）。他告诉杰森，看到一个如此年轻、对自由有如此有前途的新思想的人是多么令人鼓舞。然后他签下了承诺书。
So I'd be happy to, and I will do so right now.
所以我很乐意，我现在就签。
What does the statement say?
声明上写了什么？
It says, I hereby state my solemn intent to move to a state in the United States designated by a vote of the Free State Project.
上面写着：本人特此郑重声明，本人有意搬迁至由“自由州计划”投票指定的美国某州。
It could happen, people at the meeting tell us. It happened before. And then they talk about the so-called liberal takeover of Vermont. Back in the '70s, the demographics of the state began changing. Outsiders were moving in, a mixture of city-people, and hippies, and back-to-the-land types. And they were liberals. They elected other liberals to office, and left-leaning state policy followed. Vermont is now the only state to legalize civil unions of gays and lesbians for instance.
会议上的人告诉我们这可能会发生。以前发生过。然后他们谈到了所谓的佛蒙特州“自由派接管”。回到70年代，该州的人口结构开始发生变化。外地人搬进来了，混杂着城里人、嬉皮士和回归土地派。他们都是自由派。他们选出了其他自由派进入公职，随之而来的是倾向左翼的州政策。例如，佛蒙特州现在是唯一将同性民事结合合法化的州。
And the explanation that made the most sense to a lot of people was that there had been a conspiracy. Almost everyone we talked to brings it up. They mentioned, darkly, an article in Playboy magazine that supposedly incited the movement. The article exists, April 1972. A writer named Richard Pollak found two students at Yale, Jason's school, who proposed moving all the like-minded anti-war liberals to one state, basically Jason's plan plus hippies.
对许多人来说，最合理的解释是存在一个阴谋。我们交谈的几乎每个人都提到了这点。他们阴沉地提到了《花花公子》杂志的一篇文章，据称该文章煽动了那场运动。文章确实存在，1972年4月的。一位名叫理查德·波拉克（Richard Pollak）的作家在耶鲁大学——杰森的学校——发现了两名学生，他们提议将所有志同道合的反战自由派搬到一个州，基本上就是杰森的计划加上嬉皮士。
None of our interviewees had actually ever met anyone who'd crossed state lines because of Playboy magazine. Still if liberals could take over Vermont, why not libertarians?
我们采访的人中没有一个真正见过因为《花花公子》文章而跨州迁徙的人。不过，如果自由派能接管佛蒙特州，为什么自由意志主义者不能？
The next morning we drive to Burlington to have breakfast with the mayor, Peter Clavelle, a Democrat. I notice, a little warily, that the mayor has actually prepared for this meeting by reading the Free State Project website. He's printed out a copy of Jason's essay called "Vermont Report" and highlighted various phrases like hippie-takeover. The mayor orders an omelet, and we ask him to draw a map of Vermont showing where Jason might get support for the project.
第二天早上，我们驱车前往伯灵顿与市长彼得·克拉维尔（Peter Clavelle）共进早餐，他是一位民主党人。我有点警惕地注意到，市长确实通过阅读“自由州计划”网站为这次会面做了准备。他打印了一份杰森写的名为《佛蒙特报告》的文章，并高亮了诸如“嬉皮士接管”之类的短语。市长点了一份煎蛋卷，我们请他画一张佛蒙特地图，指出杰森在哪里能得到支持。
[INAUDIBLE] Vermont that's a little bit like this. And then fitting nicely into Vermont is New Hampshire, which is like so. And here's the Connecticut River. And I think, in terms of building this libertarian stronghold, the best bet might be to cross the river, "Live free or die," state.
[听不清]佛蒙特，它有点像这样。然后漂亮地嵌入佛蒙特的是新罕布什尔州，像这样。这是康涅狄格河。我认为，就建立这个自由意志主义堡垒而言，最好的赌注可能是跨过这条河，去那个“不自由毋宁死”的州。
And so it begins. They start debating drugs, housing, taxes, and the big one, public schools. Jason wants to eliminate them. He explains, that since taxes would be next to nothing in libertarian Vermont, people could afford to pay tuition or home-school their kids. The mayor doesn't buy it.
于是开始了。他们开始辩论药物、住房、税收，以及最大的问题：公立学校。杰森想废除它们。他解释说，由于自由意志主义佛蒙特州的税收几乎为零，人们可以负担得起学费或在家教育孩子。市长不买账。
That's fine, but how about those in our society that are less advantaged, our low and moderate income citizens, others that are vulnerable, seniors, people with physical and mental disabilities? I think if we embraced, wholesale, the libertarian philosophy, I think a lot of those folks would be left behind. I haven't heard much discussion as to how their needs and issues would be met in this utopian society.
这很好，但社会中那些处于弱势的人怎么办？我们的低收入和中等收入公民，其他弱势群体，老年人，残疾人？我认为如果我们全盘接受自由意志主义哲学，我想很多人会被抛弃。我还没听到多少讨论，说明在这样一个乌托邦社会中，他们的需求和问题该如何解决。
Then Jason does something I've never seen him do. He drops the economic theory and tells a personal anecdote. It occurs to me, this is the first time he's ever been in a situation where he had to persuade nonbelievers, liberals, or people who just don't care.
然后杰森做了我从未见过他做的事。他抛开了经济理论，讲了一个个人趣事。我意识到，这是他第一次处于不得不说服非信徒——自由派或压根不关心的人——的境地。
Well, I think my own views on that come partly from my own experience. Because I did grow up in a single-parent family, sort of at the poverty-line, four kids. I was the oldest of four. And my mom didn't believe in taking government subsidies or anything. We did kind of rely on charities for a while, and she eventually got a job at a private school. So we were able to go to the private school for free, basically.
嗯，我想我对此的看法部分源于我自己的经历。因为我是在一个单亲家庭长大的，处于贫困线，有四个孩子。我是四个孩子里的老大。我妈妈不相信靠政府补贴生活。我们确实依赖过慈善机构一阵子，她最终在私立学校找到了一份工作。所以我们基本上可以免费去读私立学校。
The public school he went to was terrible, Jason says. The private school was good. So disadvantaged kids like he was might be better off without public schools, which he considers a state-run monopoly. Pretty soon, the mayor has to go to church, and Jason talks to other people in the diner. For about 20 minutes Jason debates with one guy, who keeps saying he just can't see how it would all work.
杰森说，他上的公立学校很糟糕，私立学校很好。所以像他这样的弱势孩子，如果没有公立学校——他认为是政府垄断——日子可能会更好过。没过多久，市长要去教堂了，杰森在餐馆里和别人交谈。大约20分钟里，杰森在和一个始终说他无法想象这一切如何运作的家伙辩论。
Well, you're backpedalling. I mean, a moment ago you wanted private schools, and now you're willing to settle for just repealing Act 60.
嗯，你在退缩。我的意思是，刚才你还想要私立学校，现在你愿意为了废除“60号法案”而妥协。
Right, repealing Act 60 would just be a first step.
没错，废除“60号法案”只是第一步。
By the end of it, Jason has held his own, but he's sweating. Several people we meet warn Jason about the logistical problems his plan would invite. Among them is Anthony Pollina. He's a Progressive who ran unsuccessfully for lieutenant governor last year.
最终，杰森守住了阵地，但他出了一身汗。我们见到的几个人警告杰森，他的计划会带来后勤问题。其中包括安东尼·波利纳（Anthony Pollina）。他是一位去年竞选副州长未果的进步派人士。
You'll find, if you were to live here, that it's very difficult to change the Vermont Constitution, actually, on a practical level. Which is just something that you might want to keep in mind. It takes about eight years.
你会发现，如果你住在这儿，在实践层面上改变佛蒙特宪法是非常困难的。这只是你可能需要记住的一点。这大概需要八年。
Then there's the car situation.
还有汽车问题。
What this movement would represent to Vermont is a major problem with adequate parking. It simply would overburden the system. And we are talking about a state, largest city in the state has 30,000 people. So that would certainly represent a major influx of people. And while their intentions may be the best, their strategy of saying that we will bring this large number of people to Vermont tells me two things. They don't understand Vermont, because Vermonters will react very negatively to that, I believe. And secondly, that it actually will present a very practical burden to the state of Vermont. Which, if nothing else, will generate a lot of resentment from Vermonters.
这场运动对佛蒙特州意味着严重的停车位不足问题。它只会让系统负担过重。我们要谈论的是一个州，州内最大的城市也只有3万人。所以这肯定意味着大量人口涌入。虽然他们的初衷可能是好的，但他们说“我们将把这么多人带到佛蒙特州”的策略让我明白了两件事。他们不了解佛蒙特州，因为我相信佛蒙特人会对此反应非常负面。其次，这确实会给佛蒙特州带来实际的负担。这至少会引起佛蒙特人的巨大不满。
When we leave, Jason seems downcast by what he's heard.
我们离开时，杰森似乎被听到的话搞得很沮丧。
I mean, I don't care if Massachusetts goes communist or Utah goes fascist or whatever. They can do that if they want, so long as they maintain a democratic system. I'm just looking for a place where I and others like me can settle down and have something to call our own.
我的意思是，我不在乎马萨诸塞州变共产主义还是犹他州变法西斯主义之类的。只要他们维持民主制度，他们想干什么都行。我只是在寻找一个我和志同道合的人可以安定下来，拥有属于自己的东西的地方。
I mean, the problem is, is that other people already call it their own. We've built this up in a certain way, because this is the way we like it. And, essentially, who are you to try to undermine that or try to change that? And aren't you going to run into that wherever you go?
我的意思是，问题在于，别人已经称它为“自己的”了。我们以某种方式建设了它，因为这就是我们喜欢的方式。本质上，你是什么人，居然试图破坏或改变它？无论你去哪儿，你难道不会遇到这种情况吗？
Well, we'll run into a little bit of that wherever we go, but I also think we should be given a chance.
嗯，无论去哪儿我们都会遇到一点这种情况，但我认为我们也应该得到一个机会。
Do you feel a little bit homeless?
你觉得自己有点无家可归吗？
Yeah. I mean, I've lived in a variety of places, and that is part of the reason. I never really had that kind of a place growing up that I could say was my home. So I feel kind of homeless. I think a lot of other people do simply because of their views, they don't feel at home where they are.
是的。我的意思是，我住过各种各样的地方，这就是部分原因。我在成长过程中从未真正拥有过一个我可以称之为“家”的地方。所以我感觉有点无家可归。我想很多人仅仅因为他们的观点而感到无家可归，他们对自己所在的地方没有归属感。
We walk around downtown Burlington, and I ask Jason to give me a tour. I tell him to pretend it's the year 2050 and libertarians have been in control for 30 years. I want to know what will be different.
我们在伯灵顿市中心散步，我请杰森带我参观一下。我让他假装现在是2050年，自由意志主义者已经掌权30年了。我想知道有什么不同。
So what's that seal up there? We're looking at city hall.
那个印章是什么？我们正在看市政厅。
Well, city hall would probably still be a government building. You probably still need one. It might be smaller. Or we could probably just rent space for our meeting every month or so on the third story of this corner building or something like that.
嗯，市政厅可能还会是政府大楼。你大概仍然需要一个。它可能会更小。或者我们可能只是每个月左右在某个角落大楼的三楼租个空间开会之类的。
So would you sell city hall?
所以你会卖掉市政厅？
Yeah, if we're able to do that, yeah.
是啊，如果能做到的话，会的。
He tells me private companies would pick up the cigarette butts and styrofoam cups from the streets. On Sundays you could buy scotch and visit a brothel. Roads would also be owned by private companies, which would set speed limits and solicit billboard advertising. Zoning would disappear, so McDonald's could open up next to your house, which you could paint any color you wanted. And everyone has more money, because no one pays taxes. We cross a street to a snow covered park.
他告诉我，私营公司会清理街道上的烟头和泡沫塑料杯。周日你可以买苏格兰威士忌和造访妓院。道路也会归私营公司所有，他们会设置限速并招揽广告牌。分区法会消失，所以麦当劳可以开在你家旁边，而你的房子可以漆成任何你想要的颜色。每个人都有更多的钱，因为没人付税。我们穿过街道来到一个被雪覆盖的公园。
The sign says, City Hall Park, City of Burlington, Department of Parks and Recreation. So we we would be eliminating that department and privatizing this common here.
牌子上写着：市政厅公园，伯灵顿市，公园与游乐部。所以我们要取消那个部门，并将这块公共用地私有化。
Privatizing the common? But the sign, you didn't finish reading it.
私有化公共用地？但那个标志，你没读完。
That's right. It says, for everyone's enjoyment please no skateboarding, dogs must be leashed, no alcohol or glass bottles. Now, see, after this has been sold off, probably some of those rules would still be there. I think no skateboarding is probably kind of a silly regulation. I think that's just pure prejudice on the part of the city officials. No glass bottles, I mean, come on. That's a bit extreme too. Sort of joking, but I don't think areas like this should be tax funded certainly. It's theft, ultimately.
没错。上面写着：为了大家的享受，请勿滑板，狗必须牵引，禁止酒精或玻璃瓶。看，在这一切被卖掉后，可能其中一些规定依然存在。我认为“禁止滑板”可能是一个愚蠢的规定。我认为那纯粹是城市官员的偏见。禁止玻璃瓶，得了吧，这也太极端了。虽然是在开玩笑，但我认为像这样的区域绝不应该由税收资助。归根结底，这是盗窃。
You get something for it. You get a public space where people come together and play chess or eat their lunch. People want to come here.
你从中得到了东西。你得到了一个公共空间，人们可以在那里聚会、下棋或吃午餐。人们想来这里。
But if they get something from it, then they should be willing to support it in some way without having to be coerced into it, which is really what taxation is.
但如果他们从中得到了东西，那他们应该愿意以某种方式支持它，而不必被迫这样做，这才是税收的本质。
A company buys it, they're not going to keep it as a public park. You don't make money off a public park. So would we have no-- it would be gated. So would there be any public space? Would there be, in the city of Burlington, would we have any public space, purely public space?
公司买下它，他们就不会把它保留为公园。你没法从公共公园赚到钱。所以我们会没有——它会用大门围起来。那么在伯灵顿市，会有任何公共空间吗？纯粹的公共空间？
Purely public space? I don't think so.
纯粹的公共空间？我不觉得会有。
So this is how Jason wants to live. The free market would dictate everything and not big corporations, he says, since without big government support, they wouldn't exist. But individual business people, free to thrive in a regulation free world. What's a little weird about this vision is not that it's necessarily wrong. After all, the Founding Fathers probably would be shocked at how much power the federal government now has. It's that these fights have already been fought, and the libertarians lost.
这就是杰森想要的生活方式。他说，自由市场将决定一切，而不是大公司，因为没有大政府的支持，它们就不会存在。但个人的商人们，在没有监管的世界里自由繁荣。这种愿景有点怪的地方不在于它一定错了。毕竟，国父们如果看到联邦政府现在拥有如此大的权力，可能会感到震惊。怪的是，这些斗争已经打过了，而自由意志主义者输了。
It's very frustrating, because we're taught when we're young that the American system is an open one, that you can have an influence on, that abides by rules. But it doesn't abide by rules anymore. The government does what it wants. And the courts are in the pocket of the legislature, and we have no recourse. In other words, it's almost like we're facing a monolithic system that is almost irretrievably lost.
这非常令人沮丧，因为我们小时候被教导说美国体制是开放的，你可以施加影响，它遵守规则。但它不再遵守规则了。政府想干什么就干什么。法院掌握在立法机构手里，我们无路可走。换句话说，这简直就像我们面对一个基本上无可救药的单一制度。
Jason's hopeful anyway. As he frequently points out, seemingly stranger things have happened in America. Look at the Mormons, they basically took over a state. And there have been other historical migrations-- the pilgrims, freed slaves who fled north after the Civil War. So why not 20,000 libertarians agitated about the state of modern capitalism? Why not a group of people inspired by the anti-federalists Thomas Paine and Patrick Henry?
杰森还是很乐观。正如他经常指出的，在美国发生的更奇怪的事情都有。看看摩门教徒，他们基本上接管了一个州。历史上还有其他迁徙——朝圣者，内战后逃往北方的获得自由的奴隶。那么为什么不是2万名对现代资本主义现状感到愤怒的自由意志主义者？为什么不是一群受反联邦主义者托马斯·潘恩（Thomas Paine）和帕特里克·亨利（Patrick Henry）启发的人？
Do you ever imagine yourself having conversations with them?
你有没有想象过自己与他们对话？
Actually I do imagine myself sort of in their milieu. Yes, I have imagined myself.
实际上我确实想象过自己处于他们的环境中。是的，我想象过。
At the Constitutional Convention or  something?
在制宪会议上之类的？
Well at the Constitutional Convention or, especially, during the Revolution. Would I have been one of the people who took a stand and joined the Revolution? I think there's a very important question, because, in a lot of ways, you could argue that Americans are now much more oppressed than they were under King George. After all, that was just about a Stamp Tax. And now we have a lot more than that.
嗯，在制宪会议上，或者尤其是，在革命期间。我会是那些挺身而出参加革命的人之一吗？我认为这是一个非常重要的问题，因为在许多方面，你可以说美国人现在比在乔治国王统治下受到的压迫要严重得多。毕竟，那时候只是因为印花税。而现在，我们面临的远不止这些。
The problem for Jason is that people were mad about the Stamp Tax. But, it's safe to say, the vast majority of Vermonters are not mad about the fact that they have public parks and public schools and zoning laws. Jason doesn't see this, or if he does, he doesn't mind. After all, if he were the sort of person easily intimidated by rotten odds, he wouldn't be leading this movement. As he's waiting for his flight at the Burlington airport, I ask him whether, after everything he's heard, Vermont has moved up or down on the list of takeover states? He thinks for a second, and then says, cheerfully, up.
杰森的问题在于，人们当时确实对印花税很生气。但是，可以肯定地说，绝大多数佛蒙特人并不为他们有公园、公立学校和分区法而生气。杰森看不到这一点，或者如果他看到了，他也不介意。毕竟，如果他是那种容易被糟糕的概率吓倒的人，他就不会领导这场运动了。当他在伯灵顿机场候机时，我问他，在听了所有这些之后，佛蒙特州在 takeover（接管）州的名单上是上升了还是下降了？他想了一秒，然后愉快地说：上升了。
Sarah Koenig is a reporter for the Baltimore Sun.
萨拉·科尼格是《巴尔的摩太阳报》的记者。
Act three, the heart is a lonely junta. So what if you didn't want the regime change? What if you didn't see it coming? Cartoonist Jeffrey Brown found himself in that position in his personal life. He was writing this book-like comic about his love for his girlfriend. If you've seen this, it's these scratchy little drawings, hundreds of pages of them. Here is a typical page.
第三幕，“心是孤独的军政府”。如果这不是你想要的政权更迭呢？如果你根本没预见到呢？漫画家杰弗里·布朗（Jeffrey Brown）在他的私人生活中就处于那种境地。他当时正在写这本类似于小说的漫画，讲述他对女友的爱。如果你看过，就是那些潦草的小画，几百页。这是一张典型的页面。
So this is from the first page of a story called "Morning Shower." And in the first panel, we've just woken up. And she says, Teresa says to me, hi. And I say, good morning. In the second panel, I kind of lean over and I'm kissing her, and she's got her arm around my neck again, and her eyes are closed.
这是“早晨淋浴”故事的第一页。在第一格里，我们刚醒来。她说——特蕾莎（Teresa）对我——“嘿”。我说，“早上好”。第二格，我倾身吻她，她又搂住我的脖子，眼睛闭着。
And the third panel, I'm looking into her eyes and I say, you're pretty. And in the fourth panel, she just kind of smiles back and puts her hand on my cheek. And the next panel, I ask her, hey, do you want to take a shower together? And in the last panel, she smiles and says, OK.
第三格，我看着她的眼睛说，“你真漂亮”。第四格，她只是微笑着把手放在我的脸颊上。下一格，我问她，“嘿，你想一起洗个澡吗？”最后一格，她微笑着说，“好”。
Now this is from your book, a novel in pictures and words, called Clumsy . It's 200 pages long, and every page is pretty much some moment of you adoring her.
这是你那本名为《笨拙》（Clumsy）的图文小说里的内容。它有200页长，每一页几乎都是你崇拜她的瞬间。
Yeah, yeah. It was kind of intended to be this kind of tribute to the relationship, like a celebration of it. And while I was writing it, we ended up breaking up. So that kind of changed the ending I had planned.
是啊，是啊。它本来打算作为对这段关系的致敬，像是一次庆祝。而在我写它的时候，我们分手了。所以那改变了我计划中的结局。
Was she when one of your first girlfriends or your first girlfriend?
她是你第一任女友还是……？
She was my second girlfriend. The only other girlfriend I'd had was a two month long relationship. So it was a new experience.
她是我的第二任。我唯一的另一段恋爱是一段两个月的关系。所以这是一次全新的体验。
And so how long after you broke up were you still drawing the comic book?
那么分手后你画了多久的漫画？
About two weeks, two and a half weeks. I just remember a lot of moping, just a lot of being obviously sad. And then drawing 10 pages and then crying afterward. It's not necessarily the best way to get over someone, I guess.
大约两周，两周半。我只记得在那儿无所事事，沉浸在明显的悲伤中。然后画10页，画完哭一场。我想这未必是忘记一个人的最好方法。
So for two and a half weeks, you're basically drawing her face over and over and over again.
所以两周半里，你基本上是在一遍又一遍地画她的脸。
But, I mean, when you break up with someone aren't you just drawing their face over and over and over again anyway? So it's just like I was doing something instead of sitting there thinking about it.
但是，当你和某人分手时，难道不是无论如何都在一遍又一遍地画他们的脸吗？所以我只是在做些事情，而不是坐在那儿苦思冥想。
So you've agreed to adapt some of these to read over the radio. I should say to listeners who are listening with children, you do refer to sex, the fact that sex occurs, not with a lot of explicitness. So let's hear it.
你同意改编其中一些在电台朗读。我应该告诉带孩子的听众，你确实提到了性，提到性确实发生过，但并没有太多露骨描写。让我们来听听。
OK. So this is one of those linchpin stories that anyone with any sense realizes that something is horribly wrong with their relationship. It's called "Cigarette."
好的。这是一个关键的故事，任何有常识的人都会意识到他们的关系出现了可怕的问题。它叫“香烟”。
We're sitting outside in the motel parking lot. Someone asks if anyone else wants a cigarette.
我们坐在汽车旅馆停车场的外面。有人问是否还有人想要香烟。
"Do you mind if I have one?" Teresa asks me.
“介意我抽一支吗？”特蕾莎问我。
"You know how I feel," I say, "it's your decision."
“你知道我的感受，”我说，“这是你的决定。”
She smokes, and I go inside the motel room and listen to them through the window talking about drinking and smoking. When she's done, she comes into the room, and my shirt that she's wearing smells like smoke.
她抽烟，我走进旅馆房间，透过窗户听他们谈论喝酒和抽烟。她抽完后走进房间，她穿着的我的衬衫闻起来全是烟味。
"I came to see how angry you are with me," she says.
“我来看看你对我有多生气，”她说。
"You know I hate smoking," I say.
“你知道我讨厌抽烟，”我说。
"I don't need you making me feel like an evil person every time I do something," she says. "I gave up smoking weed for you and that's a pretty big thing. I can't hold your hand 24 hours a day, can't kiss you 24 hours a day, can't have sex with you 24 hours a day."
“我不需要你每次我做点什么时都让我感觉自己像个邪恶的人，”她说。“我为了你放弃了大麻，那已经是件很大的事了。我不能24小时拉着你的手，不能24小时亲吻你，不能24小时和你发生关系。”
I stare at the wall above her head. She sits there calmly with her arms crossed, waiting.
我盯着她头顶的墙壁。她平静地坐在那里，双臂交叉，等待着。
After you broke up, what's the strip you wrote immediately after? What's the next one?
分手后，你写的第一张条漫是什么？下一张是什么？
I think it was this Christmas story.
我想是那个圣诞故事。
OK, why don't you read that?
好的，你为什么不读那个？
This is called "Book of Kisses."
这叫“亲吻之书”。
For Christmas I draw a book of kisses for her. It has drawings of 112 different kisses, soft kisses, French kisses, nibbles on the ear, pecks on the forehead. She wants to open presents right away, and she has me open mine first. I give her the book, and she looks at it and kisses me and hugs me. She looks at it again.
圣诞节时我给她画了一本亲吻之书。上面画了112种亲吻，温柔的吻、法式热吻、轻咬耳朵、吻在额头。她想立刻打开礼物，她让我先开我的。我给她看了那本书，她看着它，吻我，拥抱我。她又看了一遍。
"My presents are never as good as yours," she says.
“我的礼物从没像你的那么好，”她说。
Is there a part of going back and drawing and then having these moments which is partly about just figuring out what went wrong?
回过头去画画并重温这些瞬间，是否部分是为了弄清楚哪里出了错？
Yeah, only in retrospect, though. Some of the stories that like seem like total foreshadowing we're just like, oh, that was something that I remember happening. I didn't think it was too bad. Then I write the story and then looking back it's like-- everyone that reads Clumsy seems to see it coming, and I just never did.
是的，不过只能事后回看。有些故事看起来像是完全的铺垫，当时我只是想“噢，那是记得发生过的事情”。我觉得并没有多坏。后来我写下了那个故事，再回看时就像——每个读过《笨拙》的人似乎都预见到了结果，而我从未预见到。
Read more.
多读点。
Toward the end of the book I kind of alternate these horrible foreshadowing stories with the sweetest possible stories that I can I think up. So this is a sweet story. It is called "Stay up Forever."
在书的末尾，我把那些可怕的预示性故事与我能想出的最甜蜜的故事交替排列。这是个甜蜜的故事，叫“永远熬夜”。
The night before she has to leave to go back to Florida, she's putting her underwear back on.
在她离开去佛罗里达的前一天晚上，她正在穿上内衣。
"What are you doing?" I ask.
“你在做什么？”我问。
"Putting clothes on."
“穿衣服。”
"But it's your last night here. Don't you want to sleep naked with me?"
“但这是你在这里的最后一晚。你不想裸睡吗？”
"But if we have sex again," she says, "I'll fall right asleep. And I don't want to sleep. I want to stay up with you forever. I don't want this night to be over."
“但如果我们再次发生关系，”她说，“我立刻就会睡着。但我不想睡觉。我想和你一直熬夜。我不想这一晚结束。”
I tell her I don't want her to leave, and I'm glad we met, and 100 other nice things.
我告诉她我不想她离开，我很庆幸我们相遇，以及100句其他好听的话。
One day, she'll tell me, she wishes she could remember all of them.
有一天，她会告诉我，她希望自己能记得所有这些。
There's a lot of really short one-page stories that I thought were just kind of really meaningless and specific to me. But apparently it's all very universal and ordinary.
有很多非常短的一页故事，我原以为它们很没意义，且对我而言太具体了。但显然它们非常普遍，很平凡。
Did friends tell you afterwards though, that these are experiences we've all had?
事后朋友们有没有告诉你，这些是我们所有人都经历过的？
Yeah, I thought, look how unique my experience was. I'm going to write about it. But that's just the opposite. It's amazing how un-extraordinary everything that happened to me is.
是的，我原以为，“看看我的经历多么独特”。我要写下来。但这正好相反。发生在我身上的一切是多么平凡，这太令人惊讶了。
You're disappointed that it's so universal?
你对自己经历的普遍性感到失望吗？
Well, not now. I was just surprised, surprised that  it was so universal. But, I mean, it was only my second girlfriend too, so it was all new to me.
嗯，现在不会了。我当时只是惊讶，惊讶于它竟然如此普遍。但是，那毕竟也只是我的第二任女友，所以对我来说一切都是新的。
Read another.
再读一个。
OK, and this one's called "Bath."
好的，这个叫“洗澡”。
The last time we had sex was at an airport hotel. Afterwards, she asked me if I would be too angry if she took a bath alone instead of a shower with me.
我们最后一次发生关系是在机场酒店。之后，她问我如果她自己一个人洗澡而不是和我一起淋浴，我会不会太生气。
And I say, "OK." I ask if I can help.
我说，“好的”。我问我能不能帮忙。
"It'll be boring for you," she says.
“这会让你觉得无聊的，”她说。
"How could I be bored when you're naked?"
“当你赤身裸体时我怎么会无聊呢？”
She lies back in the tub, and I run soap over her.
她躺回浴缸里，我给她涂抹肥皂。
"That's enough soap," she says.
“肥皂够了，”她说。
I sit on the toilet seat watching her float there with closed eyes.
我坐在马桶盖上，看着她闭着眼睛漂在水里。
"I told you this would be boring."
“我告诉过你这会很无聊的。”
"It's not," I say.
“一点也不，”我说。
She holds her nose and slides completely underwater for what seems like a minute. She pops up and pulls the hair out of her eyes.
她捏住鼻子滑到水下，在那儿待了大概一分钟。她冒出头，把头发从眼睛上拨开。
"The water is so soapy, you probably just have to get in the tub, and you'll be clean," she says.
“水里肥皂太多了，你可能只需要进浴缸，就会很干净，”她说。
She leaves and that's what I do. When I get back to the bedroom her eyes are closed, and she has the covers pulled up. I climb into bed and fall asleep holding both of her hands.
她离开了，我也照做了。当我回到卧室时，她闭着眼睛，拉起了被子。我爬进床，握着她的双手睡着了。
Jeffrey Brown, his comic book novel is called Clumsy . It's available at TheHolyConsumption.com.
杰弗里·布朗，他的漫画小说名为《笨拙》。可在TheHolyConsumption.com上买到。
Well our program was produced today by Diane Cook and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, and Starlee Kine. Senior producer Julie Snyder, David Kestenbaum, Jonathan Goldstein also worked on stories in today's show. Production help from Tom Bachman Katie O'dunn. Katie Davis's story was from her ongoing series, Neighborhood Stories , which gets funding from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting. Special thanks today Chris Babcock, Hugh Hamrick, Patricia Pyle and Susan Burton.
今天我们的节目由黛安·库克（Diane Cook）和我制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格（Alex Blumberg）、温迪·多尔（Wendy Dorr）和斯塔利·凯恩（Starlee Kine）协助。资深制作人朱莉·斯奈德、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）、乔纳森·戈尔茨坦（Jonathan Goldstein）也参与了今天节目的故事。Tom Bachman和Katie O'dunn提供了制作帮助。凯蒂·戴维斯的系列故事来自她的专题系列“社区故事”，该专题获得了公共广播公司的资助。今天特别感谢克里斯·巴布科克（Chris Babcock）、休·哈姆里克（Hugh Hamrick）、帕特里夏·派尔（Patricia Pyle）和苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责。
He says that if all those new programs that are now on public radio: Tavis Smiley, On The Media, The Next Big Thing, they want to move into that store on the corner. Go ahead, just go ahead and try.
他说那些现在在公共电台播放的新节目：泰维斯·斯迈利（Tavis Smiley）、《媒体观察》（On The Media）、《下一个大事件》（The Next Big Thing），如果他们想搬进街角那家店。去吧，尽管去试。
Boston Market went running real quick. Long John Silver's disappeared. What do you think those people don't know what business is? Let them have it.
波士顿市场跑得飞快，“朗·约翰银子”消失了。你认为那些人不懂生意？让他们试去吧，我们等着。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International
国际公共广播电台（PRI）。